hello everyone and welcome to yet
another game from the 2020 candidates
tournament I thought you'd enjoy more
than one game per day during this
wonderful tournament so here it is
ding leerin vs. Ivanka how to to
[ __ ] brawl and get out and I don't
have a photo of them shaking her hands
or anything but I do have this nice
photo of one cow checking out the
position you can see him looking very
sharp preparing to probably to refill
his glass so you can have some nice sips
of water but yeah that being said let's
check it out as this is also a very nice
one it's not as incredibly complicated
as a Giri vs. nipple but it does he does
have some very very nice moments so ding
opened with c4 he goes for the English
with d5 by bonk ow
in the g3 preparing to fianchetto the
LightSquared bishop we have Knight to f6
Bishop to g2 and Bishop to c5 and lately
Black has been giving White a lot of
problems with this line a knight of 65
and Bishop to c5 where Knight to c3 was
met with c6 and then d5 was just
incredibly strong for black so here dink
tried d3 instead he wants to choose a
different move order he wants to develop
both Knight c3 and Knight f3 in order to
prevent black from pushing d5 so black
will have to play d6 it's sort of a way
of keeping tension for for a longer
period and maybe maybe getting some sort
of a some sort of a more or less
complicated position just to play so
basically not allowing black to simplify
from the start with castles Bevan cow
and now Knight to c3
we have c6 and now Knight to f3
now putting pressure on e5 so you have
to deal with that and here we have d6
strengthening the e5 pawn we have
castles biding ending our rook to e8 and
here this has been attempted a few times
known moves are disrupted g5 and b3 by
white but here ding who goes for Knight
to a4 and it is already as a roommate in
the English that we have a completely
new game so let's see how Bank our deals
with it he heater has to go Bishop to b6
and allow this trade or if he wants to
keep the bishop
on the board he needs to go for this
Bishop b4 a5 c7 maneuver but then he
might have some problems opening up at
that bishops diagonal so let's see what
happens there should be four we have a
three forcing the bishop back Bishop a5
with B for Bishop to c7 and now not
allowing this d5 in anytime soon
we've for which yes downside of this is
that it creates a backwards pawn on the
three which will be a weakness for ding
but on the other hand black might have
some problems figuring out how to
develop the pieces with a 5 so basically
what you want to do is a 5 you want to
open open up your rook
so a5 with Bishop to b2 and now Knight
the a6 this is how long how it develops
puts more pressure on b4 we have b5
biding captures captures in the now
tonight to c5 and here then decides the
character with character Sunday for
captain c5 d captures on c5 and now it's
it's a question whether this is a is a
bigger weakness than b3 b5 is nicely
protected it is attack twice it's
definitely a target but at some point
the knight can move f6 can be played to
fortify the position and the d3 is
definitely a weakness and it's it's
unclear how Dean will deal with this and
what what is the result of this
preparation so a for strengthening the
position on the Queen side and now
Bishop to g4 by one cow
we have rook to a3 now adding a rook to
the 3rd rank to help out with the
defense here and preparing to move the
Queen so you can you can unpin here
Knight to d7 now this night would very
much enjoy coming to d4 or I will not f4
but d4 would be an excellent square for
example 97 to f8 the e6 and then at some
point maybe even d4 depending on the
wall white place so Knight to d7 biding
and now h3 pushing wrong house pressure
back Bishop to h5 and now Queen to be
one binding Quinta a1 with the attempt
of adding a third attacker here can be
very easily and met with f6 and it's a
very solid setup for
for black really numbing any any
firepower this Bishop might have had at
some point and you will also free the
df7 square for bishops you can transfer
it to do a much nicer diagonal so
instead Queen to be won by Bing and now
comes B 6 and now strengthening his
position the C 5 is now now defended and
now the knight can once again move with
Knight the d2 biding he wants to play
Bishop f3 and get rid of the light
square bishop from the board we the
Knights the f8 and now Bishop to f3 and
here if you go back for example Bishop
to g6 then dink has the option of this
should be 1 and transferring the bishop
over to this diagonal which which will
be more useful than just having it here
on g2 as it's not very likely that black
will be able to form some sort of a King
side attack so after Bishop to f3 we
have Queen to g5 now hoping for
characters captors but ding says h4
Queen has to go back while also keeping
an eye on the bishop so Queen to g6 and
now Queen d1 Dean forces a trade on f3
so Bishop captures we have Queen
captures an f3 and now not allowing
further expansion on the King side
evanka closes it with h5 we have Queen
to f5 biding also possible is knight
Knight to c4 and although this is an
excellent square for the knight you will
not have any difficulties defending this
for example f6 but okay then you can go
for example Knights the e3 and you have
available these two squares so that's
one way to go about it ding decided to
go for Queen to f5 right away his point
is if captures then captures my pawn
will nicely prevent your knight from
entering the game and maybe then I can I
can start piling up on maybe the e5 pawn
maybe bust open would f4 maybe maybe go
f3 g for g4 and g5 so a lot of ideas
here and instead of this we have instead
of this after Queen to a5 we have rook a
to d8 on houses okay we can trade but
I'm just gonna add more pressure here
develop my own developed rook and if you
trade I can get my knight into the game
so here being decides to trade we have
Queen
% g6 Knight captures and now King g2 so
like I said it's it's a question what's
a bigger weakness is this a bigger
weakness or can you do something about
this
v5 point and how can you execute well
not f5 but F 4 with f6 evanka of course
strengthens the e5 pawn and not Knight
to c4 the knight is now coming to e3 and
from there has access to d5 and f5
squares with King to f7
and now before going for this Knights
the e3 maneuver which seems very
reasonable
ding instead akise the knight on c4 and
goes to Bishop to see one he wants the
he wants to get this f4 move in a much
much quicker so rook to d7 preparing to
either double double up here or maybe to
double up here if needed for some reason
but most likely to develop on the D file
we have f4 biding and now e captures an
f4 now you cannot capture with the Jeep
on because then you hang the h4 pawn so
after it captures on f4 with Bishop
captures on f4 and then now Knight
captures an f4 Bishop captures on f4 if
you go for this then you get G captures
and you cannot go for the pawn here if
Knight captures just king g3 night here
and you lose the beasts exponents so not
something not something you'd want to do
so Knight captures an f4 we have G
captures on f4 and now it's it's a very
nice setup for white if King gets their
three then these pawns are very nicely
protected so immediately f5 one car once
the either bust open the position here
or for sting to push a five being says
okay we're gonna go with E 5 so it might
seem like your Bishop is not doing all
that much now but the bishop can easily
be transferred to d8 from where it will
attack the h4 pawn which which is a
rather weak point you could go rookie
six to g6 to g4 and then pile up on it
with the bishop so it's gonna it's gonna
be somewhat of a problem defending it
but okay rookie six a bunkhouse starts
this plan king of three and now rook the
g6 preparing to bring the rook over to
g4 but now 93 now Dean prevents the roof
from accessing the g4 square king te six
also you have to defend at five
King e6 and now comes Luke 2d one here
ding might have some plans of maybe
going located to d2 and then pushing d4
he if he gets rid of the the backwards
d3 pawn he should be ok maybe even
better so we have a continuation on the
plan Bishop to d8 now going after the h4
pawn and now the problem is if you go
something like rook to Jeet oh sorry
night to g2 to keep an eye on the h4
pawn then look the d4 is incredibly
strong and you will have too many
weaknesses here this is a weakness this
is a weakness well this is a weakness
for example whatever move you play look
the g4 is coming and now it's just there
are too many too many things to defend
if rook here then you lose the d3 pawn
so it's it would just be unplayable for
Dean so instead after Bishop to d8 move
we have looked the a2 biding and now
comes the shipped rooked d4 here just
improving the position grabbing more
space if you go for Bishop captures on
h4 it's possible but I guess he wanted
to avoid rook to h2 from being it seems
like now you kind of have to move the
bishop you could lose the h5 point and
then it's dink who actually infiltrates
the position but if you calculate it all
the way it's actually good for black
rook g3 checking e2 and now g5 this is
the the move that allows this because
now after captures and captures you do
not have the luxury of captures because
of captures so you'd have to move the
knight let's in 94 and it doesn't matter
you go after the b61 h4 and the van Hall
creates the the past h4 point even if
you get this in just look III check
you're gonna move King F 1 and now rugby
characters here and it's a it's a well
it's a winning position for black for
example captures captures you have some
problems here for example if you trade
the rooks then it's just the winning
ruled e1 check for everybody to check
could be unpleasant
also he five-point is hanging so let's
say you defended 94 but now you just go
Rudy 1 check King G - and now rook to d4
you go after the night and after this
captures you capture and now you're
threatening this you're threatening
check and it's well just a completely
winning position for black so after Luke
2
- instead of going for this right away I
guess being scared him a little bit
there with this rook - eight you move
with preparing to move it over to H to
rook the d4 but now Dean uses this moved
to shift some pieces he plays Knight to
C 2 kicks back the rook rook to d5 and
now Knight back to e3 and here ding
realizes that he is he's not the one
pushing here among how is the one
dictating the tone of the battle so he's
kind of maybe hoping for this repetition
rugby for Knight see to Knight back to
e3 and rule d5 but here we have rook the
d7 and now it's Bangkok who allows doing
a certain move but feel free to pause
the video and try to find this move
while I give you a couple of seconds as
it's quite a quite a nice one so for
those of you who are able to do it
congratulations on finding such a
beautiful freeing move like we said d3
is a weakness since the since the
beginning so what you want to do is get
rid of it for those who just wanna enjoy
the show it's d4 and it's hard to decide
on such a move when you kept on
preparing it the point is if C captures
on d4 then you have this rook the C to
move and now you have threats of rook to
c6 and it's just a just a beautiful
position if you don't capture the knight
can come to see for the b6 falls but if
capture is then for example just check
you have to defend the rook but just
captures captures and rook captures here
you go into this end game where you're
up the exchange of course you're getting
rid of this you're everything pretty
much false and it's a completely winning
position for white and if after d4 you
go rook captures which is also possible
then it's rook captures pawn captures in
the night the c2 and you've pretty much
took care of all your problems if King
if I defending you just capture it
because the bishop and the eight is
undefended
captures captures sorry captures rook C
to check King c3 and you pick up the
bishop here and now it's if King before
if you go after the point then even rook
the d6 and now black is they're really
gonna have some problems if you capture
then the point cannot be stopped if you
don't then you just start pushing the
pawn it's a very tough position for
black so after if the d7 d for beautiful
for ding but
didn't go for it instead dink went for
Luke d2 d2 he says I'm ready for your
Bishop captures on h4 and then then it's
it's my rug that's infiltrating the
position and wang hao says okay let's
see let's see what you got he played
Bishop captures on h4 and ding now
played rook the g2 because now if rook
captures rook captures then yes you do
have some problems here regarding the
well eat Luke g6 so it will be a problem
not much you can do about this for
example if you try something like King
to f7 then Knight captures an f5 really
just beautiful beautiful move for white
attacks the bishop goes after g7 and if
you don't--if after this you go for some
like rook captures on d3 then a rook to
g6 check King f7 rook captures and b6
and not with two to past points
well black also has to pass pass pawns
but it's a game you know anything can
happen but it does look like white white
2 does have some sort of an upper hand
and the f5 point is a week so this is
what ding was hoping for
however after rook to g2 he missed one
move from among how now once again feel
free to pause the video and try to find
this well beauty well I'll give you a
couple of seconds so for those of you
who do it congratulations unsporting not
so easy move to find you have to give up
the exchange and for those of you who
just wanna enjoy the show it's rook to
g4 and I'm pretty sure once ding saw
this that he was like no not not in the
first game with the white pieces why why
is this happening and now the problem is
if you capture the rook
for example Knight captures you're gonna
get H captain g4 King has to move and
then now look the d4 and now it doesn't
matter how many groups you have they're
pretty much useless this is still a
weakness this is still a weakness g5 is
coming there's nothing you can do about
that whatever you play root K 1 g5 is
coming and then after captures f4 check
King D 2 F 3 is coming and this is just
well captures with check of the pawns
the pawns are marching forward and the
day are unstoppable
so this is the problem if you captured
the roof so Dean decided not to capture
the rook
he went looked H do now just keeping the
pressure hoping that he can somehow
maybe get this rook behind maybe maybe
force the bishop to move maybe capture
on h5 but Vanko calmly played the g6 and
now he says I'm just gonna move my
bishop
I've won upon and I have a past H bond
so now Dean said okay there's not much
to be done here tonight characters in g4
we have F captors and g4 with check with
King to e3 defending his d3 pawn but now
just Bishop the back to e7 and now being
played rook a to C 2 but now h4 was
played by Wang Hao and now with the two
connected past points this is simply
unplayable and it was in this position
that the England resigned the game as
there is nothing to be done here the
rooks are useless there are no free
moves there there's nothing to be done
here and well it's just just terrible
for example it's a rook c4g 3 is coming
you have to play something let's say
rook H 1 root G 2 whatever you play you
allow the King now to enter the game or
even G 2 so it would be it would be
unplayable so yeah game 1 for ding in
the 2020 candidates tournament starts
with a loss excellent victory for Vaughn
column and I also forgot to show you
this something I know that from the
previous video I believe it's nope not
that yeah here it is I forgot to show
you their scores before
head-to-head scores before this actual
game so you can see in classical games
ding liver and beat one cow 62 with
seven rows so quite an advantage for
ding and if you include rapid exhibition
games bingler and beat one cow six to
five with 14 Ross so in faster time
controls one car does a little bit
better but regardless of what the
numbers say this game goes to one cow
and an excellent start for him into 2020
candidates tournament so it's gonna be
very interesting giri and the dinkler
and start with loss maybe some other
people as well as we are going to show
at least one more game before we check
out the standings I do hope you enjoyed
it you know it's gonna be a very
interesting tournament so even though we
all expected being really a blur
everyone anything can happen in chess as
you will know and here being started
with a loss so once again I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank Frank
combs and Jeremy Everett for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos serum
think of for watching and I will see you
soon like I said at least with one more
game from the 2020 candidates tournament
we're gonna continue to Paul Morphy saga
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world at this moment it's not
it's not much but yeah I think you'll I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day